WATCHED PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE IN
HISTORY.
>> LIVE FROM NEW YORK, IT IS
ALMOST SATURDAY NIGHT.
AS SNL PREPARES TO RAISE THE
CURTAIN ON THE 42nd SEASON, IT
IS KATE McKINNON AS HILLARY
CLINTON VERSUS ALEC BALDWIN AS
DONALD TRUMP.
THIS YEAR, SNL PUSHED ITS SEASON
OPENER UNTIL AFTER THE FIRST
DEBATE.
NOW, THE SKETCH EVERYONE IS
WAITING FOR, COULD HELP SHAPE
THE NARRATIVE OF THIS ELECTION.
WILL THERE BE TRUMP SNIFFLES.
VIGOROUS CHUGGING OF WATER.
JOKES LIKE THAT CAN BREAK
THROUGH IN A POWERFUL WAY.
THEY DEFINE PEOPLE AND I THINK
COMEDY COULD BE THE KEY TO
WINNING THIS ELECTION.
>> AS ELECTION DAY NEARS, LEFT
LEANING LATE NIGHT HOST, LIKE
SETH MYERS AND SAM B ARE WR
RATCHETING UP THEIR JOKES.
>> USED A SECRET DEVICE AND WE
HAVE A PICTURE OF IT RIGHT HERE.
>> DON'T SNORT YOUR WAY THROUGH
THE DEBATE LIKE TROUBLED.
>> POINTED COMEDY CAN TURN OFF
SOME VIEWERS.
>> I'M AWARE THAT PROBABLY
HAPPENS.
>> BUT IMPRESSES OTHER VIEWERS.
AND DURING ELECTION YEARS,
PEOPLE NEED TO LAUGH.
SOME PAST SNL IMPRESSIONS ARE
UNFORGETTABLE, LIKE TINA FEY
PLAYING SARAH PALIN.
>> I CAN SEE RUSSIA FROM MY
HOUSE.
>> AND WILL FARRELL'S GEORGE W.
BUSH.
>> STRATEGERY.
>> THE PORTRAYAL OF AL GORE WAS
DEVASTATING.
>> I WOULD PUT IT IN WHAT I CALL
A LOCK BOX.
>> AND WHO CAN FORGET CHEVY
CHASE AS GERALD FORD?
>> NO PROBLEM.
>> LAST YEAR'S McKINNON'S
CLINTON IMPRESSION HEMMELPED HE
WIN AN EMMY.
>> NOT GETTING AHEAD OF MYSELF
IN PUBLIC.
IN PRIVATE, I'VE BEEN PRESIDENT
FOR 15 YEARS.
>> AND DARRELL HAMMOND TOOK ON
TRUMP.
>> JEB, YOU'RE NICE GUY, BUT A
LIGHTWEIGHT AND I KNOW FOR A
FACT, YOU PEE SITTING DOWN.
>> BOTH CANDIDATES PAIRED ON THE
SHOW, SOMETHING WE COULD SEE
AGAIN LATER THIS SEASON.
TONIGHT, POLITICAL JUNKIES ARE
EAGERLY AWAITING SNL'S TAKE ON